why was it important to name
the album dedicated it to your boy g
in the name of g like like i get in the
name of g from in there
jesus okay but you got your man next to
you you know what i'm saying like
on the cover like what what what was uh
it's basically like
the like as far as the cover it's like
damn like he's still with me
he's on my back and i'm like you know
what i'm saying like
i don't know it's like i'm really
showing y'all like this in the name of g
like this is why y'all should follow me
if i got the sheep falling
nah i do think it's it's um obviously
man
dude was a big deal in your life you got
to change the tattoo like your album is
named after him
um do you feel like you're still like
like are you still grieving his loss or
if you feel like you come to peace with
it
nah i ain't gonna never come to peace
that's fair like some like you know how
to feeling like
you know that feeling that you get when
like um i probably
everybody had lost somebody of course of
course yeah but
it's always that reality feeling that
hits always hit you when you
when you think about a person like
actually like like
disappearing you feel me and it'd be
like that that
feeling oh hit you right in the stomach
yeah it's just always hit like that
damn man has it been how long has it
been year and a half
three years [ __ ] that's crazy
do you feel like um
because you were saying before you got
locked up you guys were the hottest in
louisiana
do you kind of feel um i saw like it
on the album you said every time you see
his kid it makes you want to cry you
know what i'm saying
um do you feel like that responsibility
to kind of like bring his people along
with you make sure his people are
straight because
you know he's not alone he's not along
with you to enjoy the ride
because right now you're at the the
biggest you've ever been you know what
i'm saying
yeah oh
i feel i i try to show as much love as i
can to
people like i mean basically like his
family i already had a relationship with
the people i had a relationship with i
ain't no y'all know
right right but what about his kid you
got a relationship with his kid yeah
like
i i gotta i got some relationship with
all the kids but
the others besides his son it'd be
harder to
to the other one the other baby mamas
yes that also all depends on how cool
the baby mama is
it's really like if i'm not giving them
no money like it's like they didn't want
to talk it's like some [ __ ] music
so oh [ __ ] yeah that's rough so you know
what i'm saying then the moment that you
don't get what they want at that moment
it's like you never did nothing so
that's crazy that's unfortunate i just
got to like realization of like last
week like i'm just done with it